We thought we would
just have a walk about
and see the damage
that we've caused.
Jelly there?
It's, like, there's paint of
several different colors.
I thought this Jell-O
would've washed away by now,
but it doesn't rain much.
That's the green one.
The red one is still sort of
dripped down the front.
Whoa!
- Oh!
- Oh, my God!
And it smells awful.
I mean, look.
Gravity has taken it
down this natural,
sort of like river,
so we've had
this stinky jelly river
for about a week
and a half.
Slightly multi-colored,
full of balloons
and balls.
We'll pick all that up.
Paint balls we've been
lobbing at the crew.
We've never shown
behind the set.
Why don't we take a walk
around here and see the damage?
Nearly got it.
Is that someone's food?
There's an old burrito.
Who left the burrito?
It tells a real story
of what's happened.
Like, get...
Hit him there.
Uh, this is...
Let's have a look
at what we've got.
Oof, taking some rounds here.
It's a very lethal set.
So we've got water balloons.
Oh!
We've got bouncy balls.
Whoa!
We've got a bowling ball.
We've got jelly.
Uh, paint.
Oh, get a shot
of under here.
Look at this.
Ping pong balls.
- Look at that.
- That's where they were.
It's also been
incredibly windy.
My lungs are, well,
a quarter sand, probably.
Do you get sand boogies,
like when the dust gets
in your nose?
Disgusting.
This is where we blew up
a load of det cord.
-  Whoa.
Gav:
Whoa, look at the shock waves.
Look, that bucket that's just
been left in there
has even got an
industrial water sign on it.
It just looks like someone's
left some industrial waste
in our set.
If I stumbled upon this,
I'd be like, "What is this for?
What happened here?
What's the purpose of this?"
And over here
we've got some--
some of our vehicles
that we used.
These are our vehicles.
This is an absolute fleet,
isn't it?
So what we've
got, we've got--
This is dropped
from a crane, then crushed
and catapult video.
( together )
Oh!
( laughter )
( gasps )
Yeah, we really bullied
this one.
Head-on crash, head-on crash.
-  What?
- ( together )  Oh!
This is from fruit stand.
Oh!
Oh, they still got
some fruit in there, look.
Oh, there's wasps in it
and everything-- bees.
And then over there we've got
our busted moving trucks.
-  Ooh!
-  Good night.
Oh!
We went out of business
immediately.
This accordion piece
is just blowing in the wind.
Got these little location signs
planted around the area.
Brilliant, yeah.
It's plastic, probably made
in about five minutes.
- Yeah, we're still excited.
- Oh, a big moment.
We've never had one before.
I want to make one
just for myself.
- Just put on your front door?
- "Dan's."
( theme music playing )
- Belly flop.
- Bear trap.
- 4K kittens.
- Paint pendulum.
4K kittens.
- You know you missed it.
- I wasn't there.
Check it out.
Dan wasn't there.
If you love episodes
without Dan in them,
check out 4K kittens.
I bet it's
the most viewed video.
Oh, I hope so.
Oh, I'd be so annoyed.